live from the beach in santa monica
california it's the 30th annual film
independent spirit awards today we mark
three decades of celebrating the
preeminent voices of independent cinema
the best and the brightest of indie film
are all gathered under one tent to honor
the top films and performances of the
year our hosts kristen bell and fred
armisen are backstage and ready to start
the show
[Music]
how did we end up here
hosting the spirit awards
smells like balls big hairy independent
balls
you used to be prince man
hey the show starts in one minute and
everything's going to hell kristen is
losing it man i need your help and
you're floating around like a weightless
buddha which is part of your process i
totally get it but i need you to get her
in line wow
i asked you not to bother me when i'm
levitating
that's how houdini died i'm sorry but
kristin is freaking out come on all
right all right all right
just explain to me what the problem is
we're supposed to be out on stage i
don't know she's not acting like herself
well i mean is that what you call
being an actress
hey
why aren't you ready we have an
important show we've gotta host this
isn't important it's an award show
during the day it's in a circus tent
well it's important to me
independent film can change an actor's
life you know richard linklater's gonna
be sitting like five feet away from us
i'm up for his next movie manhunt that's
like two weeks work for the next 28
years give me a break fred you're doing
this because like the rest of us you're
afraid you don't matter
i'm afraid that i don't matter what i
matter me afraid what what what
yeah you don't and none of it does okay
because everyone out there is already
super drunk because the liquor sponsors
put bottles of tequila on the table that
all the guests drink chrome freely two
hours before the ceremony begins
do you know who you're talking to i can
move things with my mind
it does that on its own you are so out
of touch
and what is that damn drumming
oh that's just for added tension it's
like an effect
i don't care what it's for it's driving
me crazy and it needs to stop
[Music]
would you please shut the hell up look i
gotta practice and my teacher is
literally gonna kill me well what's
happening are you rushing or dragging
what
i said
are you rushing or dragging
ow
just slap me why because i love
portlandia and you only make 10 shows a
year you lazy bastard wow why did you
slap me oh i don't know what just
happened all right i lost my place can
we please cut
no no no no no no you say please cut no
one says please cut this is all one shot
the whole thing is one shot
all right everyone back to uno back to
uno no you don't have to go back to uno
why don't we just do a two shot like
this and then just come up from me yeah
or start wide just pop in maybe cowboy
or french overs you guys all know the
terminology huh you guys are all actors
huh what does this say what does it say
l director
director
right uh what's your shirt say huh my
shirt yeah i don't think it says
anything ow
oh did we get that did we get it see ah
we got it
all right have a good show everybody
okay come on green
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
host for the spirit awards fred armisen
and kristen bell
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the 2015 film independent
spirit awards
today we are honoring some amazing
movies and the artists who made them
watching this year's top indie films
made me realize this really is the new
golden age of television that's right
that's right and it is a special day
because the show is 30 years old
coincidentally that's the age when most
independent filmmakers move back in with
their parents
um eller coltrane the wonderful kid from
boyhood is here why don't you stand up
and take a bow eller
he really did grow really grows so fast
congratulations to whiplash writer
director damian chazelle
he did something that no one has ever
done before he made jazz interesting for
people who aren't on heroin
and how about julianne moore's
performance in still alice incredible
right
let's give her a big hand
also how about julianne moore's
performance in still alice incredible
right let's give her a big hand
so many movies this year dealt with
tragedy there was of course selma which
dealt with the loss of life during the
civil rights movement and love is
strange about the tragedy of gay men who
cannot afford to live in manhattan
uh before we do anything else i have an
announcement to make uh i think the
editor of birdman is here where are you
sir
there you go so you edited this movie
what what are there like three cuts in
the whole movie i'm like
get out of here just get stand up and
walk that's not editing what did you
walk in at 10 and leave it one get out
goodbye
get out
but
in all honesty fred birdman was a really
phenomenal movie uh i'm sorry i don't
know what movie you're talking about did
you mean birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance yes fred birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance you
know there are some other movies this
year that had longer titles that people
never use like boyhood which is really
boyhood or i hope that kid doesn't grow
up fat
you know what i really enjoy dear white
people or attention whole food shoppers
and there's also dumb and dumber two or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance same
writers total coincidence so weird the
spirit awards have always honored great
low budget films the best film made for
under five hundred thousand dollars
receives the john cassavetes award some
of this year's nominees include blue
ruin
land ho
and three and a half seconds of the
hobbit
hey can i talk about something everybody
now we all watch these movies as
screeners am i correct we all have our
little screeners right listen there is a
rule you cannot give these out to your
friends all right now let me ask you a
question
does this look familiar to anybody
who's who's who's dvd is this
the imitation game kate blanchett
kate blanche these are watermarked homie
you cannot give these out you know how i
got this from my gardener
do not give these out you're ruining it
for everybody
also how about julianne ware's
performance and still alice incredible
right
[Applause]
i gotta say that fred this is actually
really fun i'm kind of surprised what do
you mean you're surprised
i don't know because you know we're so
different you and i you're like this
cool alternative guy and i'm just you
know
really popular
i i think i know what you're trying to
say
i'm a little bit indie
and i'm a little bit studio
i'm hanging out in portland i'm a disney
princess in the snow my favorite band is
flaming lips and i love broadway shows
i'm a little bit indeed
and i'm a little bit studio
selma
we feel bad what happened there
and then the oscars snubbed your actors
god it's much too much to bear
[Music]
birdman
birdman
flying around new york city new york new
york new york new york big bad city uh
huh
whiplash my neck hurts cause the white
kid's playing jazz
and that abusive
homophobic teacher he gave your film
possess
[Music]
love
is
strange
molina said i do i do i do i do i do i
do what do i do
boyhood
not girlhood
life goes by so quick
why is every
single step dad
[Music]
we both have done some
on each movies turf you did safety not
guaranteed and you're the voice of
brainy smurf you're a little bit indie
and you're a little bit studio we're a
little bit indie
[Music]
and now to present our first award
please welcome spirit award nominee
ethan hawk
[Applause]
i feel like i should break into the song
i feel really i feel like there should
be a podium
i feel uh
i feel extremely vulnerable in front of
you all right now
and i wish i didn't come but uh
it is incredible to be in this tent with
you all that is true
um it's a tremendous gathering of people
and of great minds hollywood movies
maybe keeping the industry afloat by
making these big shot movies but the
people here today are keeping the
industry alive and i am very proud to be
in this room with all of you all right
my job is extremely simple i am here to
present the award for best supporting
female and here are the nominees
best supporting female
patricia arquette boyhood you know what
i'm realizing my life is just gonna go
like that getting married having kids
getting divorced
i just
thought there would be more
jessica chastain a most violent year
this is your kid playing with a loaded
gun let me deal with it no you better
you're not gonna like what will happen
once i get involved
carmen ajogo
selma that's what they said on the end
of that phone line how they're gonna
kill my children the filth deranged and
twisted and then just
ignorant enough to be serious andreas
juarez pause stand clear of the closing
doors my son is missing
broke away beach he wait for me
yes he's waiting for you you really
think i do
i do you don't know
emma stone birdman you're doing this
because you're scared to death like the
rest of us that you don't matter and you
know what you're right
you don't
it's not important okay you're not
important get used to it
[Applause]
i have a podium and i'm much happier
okay
um
and the winner for best supporting
female is patricia arquette my closest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let me go
[Music]
get film independent spirit
it was that god
she sounded great
um
okay
all right
uh i've made a lot of independent films
and i've never been invited to this
party before so thank you for having me
here ethan
rick we've all made a lot of independent
films and i've made my living
network television and thank god for
that
but i i want to say
thank you to my incredible cast mates to
ethan hawk who gave such a beautiful
nuanced incredible performance
and boyhood and always makes work so
solid
i want to thank lorelei
and eller for your beautiful work
i want to thank
jonathan sloth and
kathleen sutherland our whole cast our
whole crew but i really want to stop for
a second and say
there should be award at this
awards ceremony for distributors because
everybody who has made a small film
knows you can make the most incredible
work of art but if you do not have a
great distributor pushing it through and
getting it seen
you will never have a chance to reach
your audience so i want to thank ifc and
jonathan searing
for that
and
oh i want to thank eric white and my
agent and manager molly madden and david
d camillo and my kids who i love so much
and thank you for inviting us to uh your
party
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there is so much more to come live from
the big tent on the beach in santa
monica julianne moore presents the
robert altman award plus zach
galifianakis kristen wiig the stars of
whiplash and many more from the 30th
film independent spirit awards returns
[Music]
welcome back everybody please let's give
it up for our fabulous house band la's
own silver sun pickups
and now the stars of the movie whiplash
miles teller and jk simmons
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
some of them were dragging a little bit
let's try that again
and they do it and they do it it's a
powerful performance chicken
um
i don't know what i we're uh yeah you
said some cool stuff and uh and then i
talked about how we're here to uh
introduce the first of five movies that
are nominated for best film this year
it is it's called whiplash it is called
whiplash it is the story of an ambitious
young drummer eager to win the approval
of his brutally sadistic and abusive
band instructor
with a heart of gold
[Applause]
uh at its core whiplash is you're much
taller in person i was telling you the
whole movie they just sat me down the
whole time the whole time it's like
unbelievable yeah it's about these two
guys go ahead uh whiplash is about the
drive for greatness and in the true
independent spirit the film was shot in
just 19 days which definitely felt like
rushing
let it go
this is whiplash
[Music]
why do you suppose i just hurled a chair
at your head neiman
i i don't know sure you do
the tempo were you rushing or were you
dragging
i i don't know
start counting five six seven four damn
it look at me
one two three four one two three four
one two three now
was i rushing or was i dragging i don't
know
count again one two three one two three
one two three rushing or dragging
rushing so you do know the difference
please welcome my only friends in the
whole world from the upcoming film
masterminds zach alifianakis and kristen
wiig
[Music]
[Music]
uh hi zach and i are here to present
best first screenplay
speaking first kristen remember the
first time we met
yes
zach i remember it like it was now
it was an intimate setting and we were
reading from a teleprompter at the film
independent spirit awards in
santa monica california
i remember
it was a balmy day and you were standing
next to me and you reeked of your car
i put on a lot this morning for this
um
oh that's you but my
but my biggest
memory of that moment
is how many ugly people were in the
audience
that day
some are even
grotesque yes like scarlett johansson is
gross
[Applause]
matt bomer disgusting looking
emma stone give me a break
but what we admire about everyone here
today
is their independence
as well as their spirit
but especially
their independence
which is brought to you by piaget the
lincoln motor company bank of america
american airlines and the republican
party
and the nominees are
desiree
appropriate behavior
desiree akavon appropriate behavior he's
having trouble dealing with like
brooklyn parties and everyone talking
about their kickstarter campaigns did
you see that guy with a wax dolly
mustache i hate so many things too
sarah collingello little accidents i
drive around a lot late at night i think
maybe i'm gonna spot him
[Music]
somewhere
it's crazy it ain't crazy
[Music]
justin later the one i love we had we
had a good time it wasn't just the weed
i mean we were connecting we were
talking we were happy we also had a
fantastic time when we did ecstasy at
lollapalooza but we're not gonna do that
every day of our lives because you die
right anya markvart she's lost control
with rona you have a kind of
professional intimacy you and i are
gonna agree
to explore
this part
of our body justin simeon dear white
people on behalf of all the colored
folks in the room let me apologize to
all the better qualified white students
whose place were taking up no it's fine
[Music]
[Music]
uh
kristen single and the spirit award
goes to
justin simeon for dear white people
[Music]
wow
i really should have written an
acceptance speech uh and said i was just
staring at oprah so uh
thank you for letting me be creepy back
there um
this
honestly this means so much to me god i
am so grateful for this uh i started
writing this movie some 10 years ago
as an impulse because i didn't really
see my story out there in the culture i
didn't see myself reflected back at me
uh in the films that i loved even in the
stories that resonated for me so i tried
to put myself in the culture and uh
you know there that can be a difficult
thing when along the way there's really
nothing there to tell you that you
belong there
so this means so much to me because it
feels like i do belong in the culture
and i just want to say
thank you
uh i'm very grateful
and if you have a story if you don't see
yourself in the culture please put
yourself there because we need you we
need to see the world from your eyes
thank you
[Music]
still to come live from the party and
the beach in sunny santa monica with
marissa tomei and alfred molina plus
kerry washington toast's 30 years of the
film independent spirit awards
independent film is all about connecting
talented people with inspired ideas at
bank of america life is better when
we're connected
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
honorary chair of the 30th film
independent spirit awards carrie
washington
as the honorary chair for the 30th
annual spirit awards
it is my privilege to be here on this
magnificent milestone over the past
three decades this show has grown from a
small dinner to an indisputable movement
showcasing nurturing and celebrating the
most talented filmmakers writers actors
and visionaries in independent cinema
film independent the non-profit arts
organization that produces these awards
has made it its mission to champion and
support a community of artists who
embody diversity innovation and
uniqueness of vision a mission which 30
years later is clearly working and
thriving let's take a look back at 30
years of the spirit awards
this ought to be fun they said it's some
kind of indie film initiation ritual or
something like that
it's dennis harper
independent film is where stuff actually
happens you know it's not easy to make a
movie
it offends just about everybody everyone
in this room understands what it's like
to give your heart and soul to something
without getting paid a dime the only
thing that's motivating you is a belief
and a story that you love enough to do
almost anything for it really isn't the
wallet that makes the movie it's your
creativity your passion we made this
little movie just for love not for money
not for glory
and it turns out that people actually
like it but i like this independent
thing i like that they
went around and they
begged and they borrowed and
in some cases they did steal
nobody can really be independent in
making movies we all owe a great debt of
thanks to todd haynes's body of work one
thing i'd like to get off my chest i did
carvier bartend
[Music]
and phillip seymour hoffman is the
product of our union and i want to thank
all the women i've been with and all the
women who think they've been with me
i've been trying to make a movie like
this for a long time i really appreciate
you letting me be a part of it it's a
great honor
deserve it
but what about the unsung heroes the
actors you tolerate me you really
tolerate them i love my profession
i love what we do
this is just amazing i want to share
this so badly i can't tell you really
without independent films i'd be nowhere
this is wonderful i i i
really don't know what to say you're
crying at the independent spirit awards
come on get together four years ago i
was awaiting tables
here at the spirit awards
please keep your acceptance speeches
short because this tent has to be at a
bar mitzvah at 5 pm i've never been
nominated for anything before
this may never happen again if i do this
quick do i get a free tv
the thing is do what you do and
i guess that's what i got to say it's
taken me the longest time to realize
that the
spirits awards
have nothing to do with booze every
single person involved in this film
completely transformed my life i thank
my wife for um
telling me at one point during my acting
career that i was a bloodless actor and
i needed to get in touch with my
emotions so i could communicate to
people hey wes anderson hal ashby called
he wants his establishing shots back
this is all a director like me can ever
hope to get the last time i held one of
these in my hands here was 19 years ago
i had to take my pants off to win a
trophy
this is really going to tie the room
together baby really truly truly truly
thank you and i hope to see everyone
here again
please raise your glasses and join me in
a toast to 30 years of film independence
spirit awards saloon
[Applause]
please welcome a spirit award nominee
for her performance in still alice
julianne moore
[Music]
[Applause]
when i was 19 and attending college in
boston i regularly went to a revival
house in cambridge called the brattle
theater
yeah
one time i stumbled on robert altman's
three women and i was captivated it was
the first time i had actually
experienced directorial point of view
and it completely changed my ideas about
acting what i wanted to do in the future
i was lucky and 12 years later bob
called me and i had the great privilege
of working with him on both shortcuts
and cookie's fortune
so i am especially excited to present
the robert altman award given to a film
that echoes his distinctive style
this year that movie is paul thomas
anderson's inherent vice
if altman has an heir apparent it's paul
thomas anderson
bob love paul and paul love bob it shows
in every shot pt takes and in the
beautiful humanity of his screenplays
much like an almond film inherent vice
treats us to overlapping plots and
subplots plus unforgettable
one-of-a-kind characters all drenched in
the technicolor drug haze of early 70s
los angeles it is a trippy ambitious
gorgeous psychedelic saga this is
inherent vice
well morning sam what's up doc
congratulations
welcome to a world of inconvenience
what's up doc films aren't made like
this very much anymore what's your
ex-girlfriend it's hasta fay hepworth
have you had any contact with her in the
last a week or so how funny you should
ask doc hadn't seen her in over a year
[Music]
that you just thinks he's hallucinating
i think anyone that worked with paul
would do well and i think it's part of
it is that he's just genuinely kind of
searching and trying to discover it he
needs your help doc he directs the way
actors act
he inhabits the world as well you ready
keeping a close eye to spend an hour on
surface streets trying to make it look
good there's a great dynamic that
happens once in a while when you finish
a film like this you look back and you
go you're just honored to be in the film
oh you feel like a cop almost don't you
[Music]
mind
[Music]
it was weird that in the limited space
of a postcard shasta should have chosen
to remember that one day in the rain
every time i see it there's i see new
things that's paul right there and and
perhaps the book as well michael z
wolfman has vanished mickey wolfman
might not be as missing as we thanks
we were comfortable working together you
all feel like you're in this story
together
are you all right am i are you
panicking
[Music]
i miss those days
i miss you
will i still be in your eyes and on your
mind
film independent is pleased to present
the 2015 robert altman award to director
paul thomas anderson casting director
cassandra cula kundas and the cast of
inherent vice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will you think of me
and wonder if i'm
[Applause]
i think robert altman would have been as
humiliated as i am about that clip
about saying all those nice things in
front of you but um we have a beautiful
cast thank you for inviting us thank you
for this award
which i share with cassandra
i guarantee no director in this room
had all the ideas for who to put in
their movie they needed a casting
director
and they never get any credit
do you want to say something i i just
want to thank the independent spirits
for having this award obviously because
it's uh casting is an integral part of
filmmaking which isn't recognized so
thank you for even thinking of us and
for this cast which is an embarrassment
of riches
and this is only like a quarter of them
we had like 72 speaking roles and
they're all amazing so we want to thank
them for doing an amazing job and
being in our film yeah it's not hard to
work for this one i mean you know
i won't say anything nice or wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have much more to come as the stars
gather at the beach live last year's
spirit award winner jared leto hands out
this year's best supporting mail trophy
plus emmy rossum michael pena and aubry
plaza when the 30th film independent
spirit awards returns
the lenscrafters truer than fiction
award goes to dan kraus for the kill
team my name is dan kraus i'm the
director of the kill team the kill team
is the story of a u.s soldier in
afghanistan who attempts to alert the
army to atrocities his unit is commuting
and who then himself is charged with
premeditated murder having recognition
of this kind feels like someone has
suddenly pulled back the curtain and let
in the light and you can see all these
people around you and they're supporting
you and appreciating the work that
you're doing
thank you film independent and thank you
lenscrafters
welcome back everyone i'm so sorry i do
have to make a quick announcement um i
don't know whose car it is but there is
um someone's blocking the valet stand
it's a 1989 batmobile with the vanity
license plate keaton rules
so
whoever it is the attendant is going to
need your keys
and now please welcome from love is
strange marisa tomei and spirit award
nominee alfred molina
[Music]
when i heard that iris sax was making a
new film i asked if i could be in it
before i even read the script i did i
feel so grateful to be part of this
beautiful
intimate film love is strange
alfred and john lithgow play a longtime
couple who due to financial hardships
find themselves forced to live
separately with family and friends
we should all be so lucky to have either
of these guys move in with us
now i know what you're thinking every
hollywood movie is all about married gay
couples in the early winter of their
lives but this one i've got to tell you
is very very different it's special
because it's about the decision to be
who you are no matter what the
consequences but really it's an enduring
love story as universal as any other uh
with great pleasure this is love is
strange
[Applause]
to stay away from you
and it takes more than a lifetime
to prove that i'll be true
and it takes somebody special
to make us say we do
and baby
you've got what it takes okay here we
take it home now
and baby
you've got what it takes
not just in the kitchen
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome emmy rossum and michael
payne
[Music]
as actors michael and i take our jobs
very seriously we research each scene as
thoroughly as possible to make sure we
understand our roles completely totally
which is
yeah for sure
which is why when we were asked to
present
the award for best international film
i immediately called the spirit awards
of officers requesting flights to sweden
england
canada
russia poland and i said you know what
throw in the philippines
but a nice woman there told us that
those flights were not in the budget and
instead we should just watch the
nominated films on the free screeners
they gave us
so at least we got free screeners right
we watched them and they were incredible
and here are the nominees
best international film
force major yeah we saw an avalanche
quite quickly it grew
it was quite shocking
mommy
[Music]
we are asking your lord jesus to help
him my
[Music]
come to me
[Music]
and the spirit award goes to
eda oh
[Music]
wow
thank you amazing
i realized we're at an independent
event when i was queuing up for the
toilets you know
there's like 30 people ahead of me felt
very i felt very at home
so um
so yeah this is a great great honor also
seeing these clips from the other films
the films i love you know the first
major mummy leviathan
what a what a competition so you know
it's doubly exciting you know and thank
you my competitors for for losing this
timeline
um
so yeah and i'd like to thank above all
the people who made this
help make this film possible and help me
make it independently eric abraham
piotr
eva pustrinska agnieszka aldarovic from
the polish film institute uh and you
know there was it was we did everything
to make a film that you know that nobody
watches black and white camera doesn't
move
hardly any script but miracles happen
thank you very much
[Applause]
the most star-studded beach party on
earth continues with olivia munn and
craig robinson plus the driving force
behind the powerful selma oprah winfrey
when the 30th film independent spirit
awards continues live from santa monica
[Music]
fred
fred
what are you doing we have to intro the
next two presenters was that now yeah
it's now it's the middle of the show man
oh i'm so sorry about that
okay let's just introduce them from here
can we do that
okay
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
diego luna and spirit award nominee
jenny slate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
one of the most hallowed names in the
history of independent film is john
cassavetes
he was a working film actor who financed
produced and directed his amazing films
right which is why whenever someone
stars in produces and directs their own
film in the biz we like to say you
cassavati the [ __ ] out of that movie man
they
they they do that i've never heard of it
i think if they haven't done it they
should because i sounded very cool when
i just did it
yes you did thank you yeah well with
pride we present this year's john
cassavetes award to the best future
produced for under five hundred thousand
dollars here are the nominees
the john cassavetes award
blue ruin
i know this is personal that's how
you'll fail no speeches
you point the gun you shoot them
[Music]
it felt like love did you do something
stupid it's kind of a blur
how blurry did you sleep with him
land ho i bought us two first-class
tickets to iceland the juicy fantastic
lobsters and the gorgeous broads
i don't like lobster man from reno
i'm investigating a homicide all the
clues were in that suitcase
clues i write mystery novels
test
it seems so unnatural though just being
with one person it's like some sort of
massive unnatural challenge
it's like a
[Applause]
and test spirit award goes to
land hoe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
this is pretty great um thanks so much
i guess we should definitely thank game
changer
they financed this film
and they let a girl like me
make a movie with dick jokes and fart
jokes and um be their first film out the
gate so that's cool
i'm gonna talk
yeah as instructed we're gonna keep it
short so thank you to our distributor
sony pictures classics thank you to my
wife elizabeth mckee and uh thank you to
all these wonderful people that i made
this movie with
um
just uh really quickly i wanted to thank
piaget for giving me 25 thousand dollars
two years ago uh for the producing award
and thanks for thank the film
independent for supporting me throughout
my entire career and one last thing i
have a message for dave boyle the
director of man from reno wherever you
are suck it dude thank you
please welcome aubry plaza and the
creator and star of togetherness mark
duplass
[Applause]
[Music]
hi aubry hey how's it going great so
guys we're here to present the award for
best first feature
uh mark i'm so mad at you
why why are you mad at me because i
wasn't in your first feature how could
you do that to me
so wait are you like really mad at me or
you're doing like the award show mad at
me thing for for the thing
fake awards show mad
all right i'm fine with that that's we
can do that
okay great
that looks like you're really mad at me
now that's because i hate you
okay good and the nominees for best
feature
best first feature are
best first feature
a girl walks home alone at night
dear white people
weaved
really [ __ ] say it right please it's
weave noun
night crawler crash with injuries just
occurred western and third the moment
has arrived the critical moment start
filming we want all of it obvious child
i'm getting a little dizzy well you're
dizzy because you played russian
roulette with your vagina
she's lost control
you like looking at me do you not feel
safe with me you think you've got me all
figured out can you just give me one
second
[Music]
all right
and the spirit award goes to
nightcrawler
oh
thank you this award goes to the
filmmaker and also the producers of the
film so i'd like to introduce
betsy danbury michelle litvack
jennifer fox david lancaster
gary michael walters who's not here is
my brother tony gilroy and jake
gyllenhaal who's a producer i'd also
like to thank jake one of the most
deeply talented committed and fearless
actors i believe alive today
rene russo is here who inspires me on a
daily basis
ahmed who gave i thought a
transformative performance
i thought was terrific
very quickly i'd like to thank my
brother john gilroy who is my editor
robert ellsworth who is my
cinematographer everybody at open road
tom wartenberg jason cassidy and liz
bieber for just crushing our release
thank you so much
scott greenberg my agent my daughter
rose who flew here from from bitter cold
in the east coast and i this likely last
to finish by saying that independent
film the the the foundation and
everybody here today i think are
holdouts against a tsunami of superhero
movies that have swept over this
industry we have survived and we have
thrived and i think that's true spirit
thank you
[Music]
when we return live from the big tent on
the beach we'll have emma stone and the
boy we watched grow up in boyhood eller
coltrane when the 30th film independent
spirit awards continues
[Music]
okay don't be nervous kristen here we go
ready hold on come back come back i'm
out here we go
here we go
ladies and gentlemen
orpah winfrey damn it no sorry sorry
about that it's okay it's okay ladies
and gentlemen oprah winfrey
[Applause]
to me
selma
is more than just a movie
because we all need to know where we've
been so we can move forward
together
the story of those brave men and women
who march just 50 years ago
still resonates to this very day
the struggle for equality is not easy
it never was
they tried to march to montgomery three
times
and eventually
with god's grace
and martin luther king's leadership
they succeeded
they overcame
and with it
they brought us all another birth of
freedom
this is their story
this is our story
this is selma
as long as i am unable to exercise my
constitutional right to vote i do not
have command of my own life
i cannot determine my own destiny what
is determined for me by people who would
rather see me suffer than succeed
those that have gone before us say
no more
no more
that means protest that means march
that means disturb the peace that means
jail
that means risk and that is hard
we will not wait any longer
give us the vote
that's right no more
we're not asking we're demanding give us
the vote
please welcome last year's spirit award
winner for best supporting male jared
leto
[Music]
[Applause]
it's great to be back here at the beach
with my fellow freaks and friends who
love to make films that leave them
penniless jobless and in a great deal of
pain
you know who you are uh
some of you know from last year i had a
rather long thank you list but still i
was informed of a number of thank yous
that i egregiously omitted so without
further
ado that frog that i accidentally
squeezed to death in second grade thank
you for teaching me how short life truly
can be
uh richard simmons for my flexibility
endurance and uncanny fashion sense
all of my homies at pequito moss on
ventura boulevard
and
last but not least my grandmother for
beating me senseless with a fly swatter
teaching me that you can't get away with
everything that you think you can
respect your elders unless you want a
can of whoop ass
the nominees for best supporting male
are
best supporting male
[Applause]
rhiz ahmed nightcrawler okay i want more
money
a lot more you're talking about some
seriously messed up [ __ ] you're just
expecting me you should just go along
with it i want more ethan hawk
there is no favorite beetle you get paul
takes you the party george talks to you
about god
john who says now it's about love and
pain and then rico just says hey
enjoy what we have while we have it
alfred molina love is strange you've all
known this whole time that ben and i
have been living together let's pray i
still believe in jesus christ as my
savior that won't change but this moment
i think i'd like to pray on my own
edward norton birdman you guys know that
if you crank out any toxic piece of crap
people will line up and pay to see it
but long after you're gone i'm gonna be
on that stage earning my living bearing
my soul wrestling with complex human
jk simmons whiplash look up here look at
me
do you think
you're out of tune
yes then why the [ __ ] didn't you say so
and the spirit award goes to
jk simmons
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you film independent um
it occurs to me that i've been
ridiculously
blessed um in my life
thank you michelle
and um
and particularly this year with with all
this uh lovely attention and being able
to stand up here at some of these
podiums my career has been blessed
one thing that i have not
done previously is
is point out how honored i am and i know
people use that word i was trying to
think of a better one there isn't a
better one how honored i am to be
mentioned with these other actors edward
and ethan and rizz and freddie uh
i i actually got to see all your films
this year which
i don't often do and uh and your work is
wonderful and inspiring and i'm uh
i'm very honored to be
counted among your number um
please
i owe thanks of course to uh everybody
at my table
damian and miles and jason and jason and
helen and cooper and everybody at
blumhouse everybody at bold thank you
guys for getting this movie made thank
you to tom and michael at sony pictures
classics for getting this movie seen
and uh and everybody who hasn't seen the
movie
it's still out there
my uh
my wife
deserves my thanks
on many levels first of all for
growing up and moving behind the camera
which is lovely because it means more
work for me
and um and also for being a brilliant
mother to our two above average children
who were not interested enough to bother
coming here today but uh
maybe they're watching on television of
show hi
thank you
[Applause]
we have so much more to come with the
awards for best director best female
lead and best male leads still to be
handed out plus ewan mcgregor and the
stars of selma karma najoko and david
oyelowo it's all happening live on the
30th film independent spirit awards
[Music]
the kiels summon the watch award goes to
rania t and daniel garcia my name is
rania and i'm daniel garcia and we are
the co-writer directors of h h is a
science fiction drama which follows two
women who slowly devolve into madness
after an alleged meteor strike sets off
a series of strange events in their town
we've been working extremely
independently for a while so this is a
good acknowledgement of the effort we
have been doing it means we're doing
something right thank you film
independent thank you since 1851.
in the film birdman we hear the
character's inner monologue voice
throughout the film
and uh they shot this with a special
birdman inner monologue camera yeah
they're really cool and we are very
lucky we have those cameras here today
so we can actually hear what some of the
people in the audience are thinking
let's try it out
oh my god oh my god i met oprah and i
told her i saw selma but i didn't and i
feel like she could totally tell
what
really
huh i hope she saw that
i had some fish
and i had rice
and i had i had some some salad
and
what is this guy doing
come on
[Laughter]
i'm a pescatarian but i hate saying
pescetarian because it sounds like i
take myself too seriously
actually i hate cheese today i'm not a
pescetarian
there's no pronoun for us i'm just me
yeah
i'm michael keaton man that's me that is
me
me
i wish i had a mustache
ah so so so bright in here
who's
who is this who's behind me oh let me
check my phone yeah who's gonna
i guess he's doing pretty well fred's
doing great
perez doing good yeah
usually i'm the most talented christian
in the room but not today
hats off to that sassy blonde oh my god
she's on
he's so stupid
dumbest guy around i wish he knew how to
do i wish he knew how to do myth and
spell
and
i wish he could put sentences together
wow
that was an incredible camera
she was and now coming to the stage
olivia munn and craig robinson
[Applause]
[Music]
screenwriters in independent film have
an interesting relationship with credit
hogs
or as the rest of us call them directors
but a lot of independent films are
written and directed by the same person
giving them the artistic freedom to hate
themselves
but today we hope writers and writer
directors can come together as friends
and talk nasty [ __ ] about producers
here are your nominees for best
screenplay
best screenplay
scott alexander and larry karaszewski
big eyes
i painted every single one of them
every big eye
me
and no one will ever know but you jc
shandor a most violent year one of you
or two have been allowing this to happen
by buying it from these cowards or worse
yet hiring them to do it so what i'm
saying is stop dan gilroy nightcrawler
we have what could be considered an
almost exclusive relationship there are
many other places i could go
[Music]
i have to think that you are invested in
this transaction jim jar moosh only
lovers left alive
give my regards to that suicide leader
romantic scoundrel
well let's hope he's just romantic
ira saxa mauricio zacharias love is
strange do you ever blame me for all of
this
all i know is that after 39 years it's
hard to fall asleep without you
[Music]
and the spirit award goes to
dan gilroy nightcrawler
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much you're very generous
i'll keep it brief
um
obviously a high point
we are we work in careers where these
moments are rare i will share with you
that
10 years ago at a low point in my career
i was not far from here and i actually
thought that what i did was the
equivalent of writing in the sand
because the ocean would come up and wipe
it away that's things were not getting
made so it's very sort of symbolic for
me to be accepting a ward where
i had a revelation that what i do i do
because i love and i think that's why we
all do what we do
and so the award is
means a lot terrific amount i'd just
like to thank my mom and dad who i
didn't thank me for and to thank all of
you
and uh the other people who were
nominated with i actually think we could
have called our film big eyes i think
that would have been appropriate but
they took it from us so thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
when we return we hand out the spirit
awards for best documentary and best
director alexander payne presents the
special distinction award plus scarlett
johansson and cate blanchett all live
from the beach when the 30th film
independent spirit awards continues
welcome back before today's broadcast we
presented spirit awards for editing and
cinematography i'd like to acknowledge
our winners
for best editing tony cross for whiplash
and best cinematography emmanuel lubesky
for birdman
congratulations to both
and now please welcome the beautiful and
talented emma stone
oh fred i'm not that talented
in a disorganized dressing room we first
meet our disheveled hero levitating
above the ground what follows is a
brilliant continuous stream of motion
and magic as we journey into the bowels
of a broadway theater it's the story of
an aging action hero desperate for
artistic credibility it's a relentless
exploration of fame ego and mortality
and as much as i love acting in this
film i loved watching it even more this
is
birdman
my father was a mean [ __ ] drunk
that was okay though you know so this
was beating us he wasn't thinking about
taking it
he was head to his tool shed because
we're gonna have the tool shake that
so [ __ ] would smell like it
say he want to get down here he's on top
of my belt oh do you want me to take it
off and use it on you
after a while i may myself know himself
you know but
okay okay okay hey hey hey hey
hey oh god uh
i i didn't no i'm
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's that is
that's [ __ ] horrible man i'm sorry
yeah
it's also not true
see i can pretend to you oh oh me mike
i'm telling you you're a little bit
crazy
yeah yeah you have no [ __ ] idea so
working with rick and johnson's like
waltzing with the monkey huh i might
have said yeah yeah you come on let's go
come on yeah yeah
why don't you get your wings in your
[ __ ] bird suit
[Applause]
please welcome the director of the
spirit award winning films election
sideways and nebraska alexander payne
[Applause]
[Music]
uh this year film independent presents
its special distinction award to the
unsettling and absorbing foxcatcher
fox catcher depicts the truth depicts
the true story of an eccentric and
emasculated billionaire
who
who sponsors an olympic wrestler who in
turn wants to emerge from the shadow of
his older brother
the escalating psychological warfare
played out in the lush hills of
pennsylvania makes for a mesmerizing
piece of cinema
and the weirdness of the story aside
in my book fox catcher is one of the
most touching portrayals of brotherhood
that i've seen in a recent movie
anchored by wonderful performances from
steve carell channing tatum and mark
ruffalo
and directed with great humanity and
precision by bennett miller
fox catcher is a perfect choice to
receive this year's special distinction
and now here's a look at fox
[Music]
you catcher any idea who i am
and i want to speak with you about your
future
what do you hope to achieve mark you
want to be the best in the world
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who are you gonna train with
no
no
i meant
we as in me and you together picking a
team
mr dupont and i would love to have you
what's he get out of all this
i want
more than anything
to win a gold medal and we have someone
who could do that well we're gonna win a
gold medal john
mark you have been living in your
brother's shadow your entire life
it's your time now
this could be a real good thing for you
i'm proud of
you i am leading men
i am teaching them
i am giving them
a dream
and i am giving america
oh
[Music]
it's really a wonderful film and it
gives me great pleasure to welcome
bennett miller to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
uh
it's an honor to receive this from you
alexander and thank you for that
um
i feel very fortunate to get to
make the kinds of films i'd like to make
and work with the people that i get to
work with
uh and i'm genuinely and deeply grateful
for the recognition
and to all
who gave themselves to this particular
film thank you
[Music]
when we return to the big tent on the
beach jessica chastain and andy sandberg
will award the best male lead plus cate
blanchett presents the biggest spirit
award there is best feature it's all
still to come live at the 30th film
independent spirit awards
[Music]
hi while we're in the american airlines
lounge the most exclusive lounge out of
all the other lounge tents here on
lounge tent road we would love to be in
the big tent with all your regular folk
but when you can get in to a tent lounge
this exclusive you kind of gotta take
advantage of it and not just anyone can
get in here
right
jennifer lopez
absolutely
pope francis
but now this next young man just turned
20 years old to us though he'll always
be six to 18. please welcome from
boyhood eller coltrane
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2002 i was six
and i started making boyhood with
richard linklater ethan hawk patricia
arquette and laura linklater
and it has accompanied me through more
than half my life and
it's always been a reflection of my
thoughts and experiences and an attempt
to
maybe express something that we all feel
and it's been a hell of a ride
and um
as it seems to be coming to a close
i find myself really grateful to
everyone who was a part of it so this is
boyhood
do you still love dad
i still love your father
but that doesn't mean it was healthy for
us to stay together
what if after we move
he's trying to find us and he can't
well that won't be a problem
he can call grandma and she'll tell him
or he can call information
we won't be hard to find
is he still in alaska
no that's what your uncle says
i like him in polar bears or something
yeah i hope they're taming him
please welcome spirit award nominees and
the stars of selma carmen ajogo and
david oyelowo
carmen and i had the great honor and
privilege of playing dr martin luther
king jr and his wife caretta bringing to
life a transformational moment in
america's history
and the nominated films for best
documentary are historical documents of
their own show katie sings some of our
most extraordinary stories and people
here are the nominees for best
documentary
best documentary
20 000 days on earth
songwriting is about counterpoint like
letting a small child in the same room
as a mongolian psychopath citizen four
you know you're not gonna bully me into
silence like you've done to everybody
else
and if nobody else is gonna do it i will
stray dog grab my throttle crank it down
get highway eastward
michigan action never came home the
government tells us to leave it alone
the salt of the earth so one thing i
knew already about the sebastian salgado
he really cared about people
the ronga
the national park is the only hope this
region has
if we leave we would lose everything
and the spirit award goes to
citizen fall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
thank you to the independent spirit
awards this is great honor
i'll just say one thing before laura and
glenn maybe i will say a few words
this film was made under great secrecy
and it took enormous risks to make it
and we are very thankful to partners and
organizations who have been fearlessly
with us
and we would like to thank especially
brit dock with jess beady and
jason beatty just searched and beatty
kinsey
sundance
josh brown
nancy willin and ryan werner
um radius meaning jason genego and tom
quinn
participants diane werman and jim burke
and hbo sheila nevins and sarah
bernstein thank you so much
so as you can see by all the people on
the stage this has been an incredible
collaboration and many people have been
involved in the film um but there's one
person without whom this reporting would
not happen this film would not happen
and the international debate around
privacy would not happen and this is my
colleague glenn greenwald
um
a lot of people talk about this film as
though it's about a subversion of
privacy and i think it's actually much
more about a subversion of democracy if
we
don't know the most important acts that
our government is doing because it's
kept from us then we don't really have
meaningful democracy and that's why
really brave whistleblowers like daniel
ellsberg and chelsea manning and
especially the stunningly courageous
edward snowden deserve not decades in
prison but our collective gratitude
thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the biggest spirit awards are still yet
to be handed out scarlett johansson
presents the best director award and
ewan mcgregor awards the best female
lead plus the spirit awards for best
male lead and best feature when the 30th
film independent spirit awards return
live
i'm chris olsen i'm the recipient of the
piaget producers award i produced a film
called camiko the treasure hunter it's a
movie really about following your dreams
no matter what obstacles are in your way
the psja producers award comes with a
wonderful unrestricted grant this grant
allows me to push forward some projects
that are going to be trickier to finance
i've made movies for 25 000 i can go
make another movie thank you film
independent and thank you piaget
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen star of the
upcoming micro budget indie film
avengers age of ultron scarlett
johansson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a truly great film starts with a bold
vision
but that vision can only become reality
through the skill
and the will
that rhymes of an unrelenting director
these five men and women nominated for
best director each had the strength to
mold their own unique vision
into a powerful reality on screen
and the nominees are
damien chazelle
for taking us inside the cutthroat world
of a prestigious music academy in the
rhythmic high octane drama whiplash
ava duvernay
who showed us martin luther king in 1965
as a man
not a legend during the heated and
difficult struggle for voting rights in
selma
alejandro g inarritu
who exposed the internal desperation of
an actor hungry for
[Music]
relevance using the camera and his
startling groundbreaking immersive style
in birdman
richard linklater
who utilized a revolutionary narrative
technique showing the actual passage of
time in a family's evolving dynamic in
boyhood
and david zellner
for his compelling portrait of a
confused 20-something japanese girl who
embarks on an adventure to minnesota in
kamiko the treasure hunter
and the spirit award goes to
richard linklater
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm not richard linklater but i play
him in movies
um
uh rick can't be here tonight today but
i will tell you this i've made eight
movies with him and i've been his friend
for 20 years and i can tell you there's
no community he's prouder to be a part
of than this one he doesn't need to be
selected out it's an honor enough to
walk among you especially
this group that's here this year it's
amazing to be here and if this movie
serves as anything it serves as a little
um
flare gun you know to shoot up
for anybody that has a radical vision
that has something that they want to say
that they think somebody should be
hearing
um it is possible 13 years ago when rick
presented to me this idea i can
guarantee you besides his artistic
collaborators there was only one person
in the world that thought it was a good
idea and that man is jonathan searing
right there okay
and
but the truth is
you know
the impossible can happen and it's what
rick always says is it's the wild west
out there this art form is so young and
there's so much to be done there's so
many stories to be told and it's going
to be told not by corporate america but
by you so thank you so much have a great
night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when we return jessica chastain and
former spirit award host andy sandberg
present the award for best male lead and
we will reveal the winner of best
feature live on the 30th film
independent spirit awards
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome ewan
mcgregor
hello
for actors there's no bigger feat or
responsibility than playing the lead in
a movie
you're tasked as the story's navigator
and it's up to you to deliver a
performance that's consistent
magnetic and true
the five nominees for best female lead
did just that
leading us on journeys will not soon
forget and here they are
best female lead
marion coatiard the immigrant
can you help me they're sending me back
no no no
i can work
you know this man you talk to them rinco
kikuchi
this is not real
real
and this is a normal i discovered
treasure
right here julianne moore still alice
why won't you take me seriously no i
know what i'm feeling i know what it's
feeling and it feels like my brain is
dying and everything i've worked for in
my entire life is going
jenny slate obvious child i don't know
if you're getting my messages but
i really
would need to i wouldn't talk
and there will not be an apology message
for this apology message goodbye
tilda swinton only lovers left alive
come on tell me what was she like she
was delicious i bet she was checkmate
you're brutal
and a survivor baby
and the spur award
goes to
julianne moore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah thank you very much
um
thank you for letting me be a part of
this community i didn't expect to feel
so emotional i've been making
independent films for almost 25 years
now
yeah
i was uh
i was kind i was lucky enough to to kind
of come in at the beginning of the
independent film
movement and it's really shaped my life
and uh and and my career and i i made
this movie with some old friends of mine
um pam cuffler and christine vashon of
killer films
michael barker and tom bernard of sony
classics we've all worked together many
times and it's always a privilege to
work with you
um we made this movie in 23 days
um for four million dollars i brought my
own bras and my own food
i begged my friend alec baldwin to do it
i can remember hearing our great
cinematographer daniel noir yelling to
rich and wash to hurry up because our
light kit wasn't even strong enough to
shoot inside after five o'clock
and we did it and we loved it and it was
such a privilege to get to work on this
story it's a particular privilege to
work with wash westmoreland and richard
glatzer who are true independent
filmmakers
they
they made a beautiful story of what it's
like to live with alzheimer's to live
with a degenerative disease while
dealing with their own degenerative
disease um because they believe that
film is important and and
you feel less alone when you watch them
because it talks they talk about what
it's what a thrill it is to a thrill and
a privilege it is to to be alive this
film is their accomplishment
um i wish they were here today i really
really
do they should be very proud and i want
to thank them for this the privilege of
working with them and for this gift of a
part thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome my
two favorite jessicas jessica chastain
and andy samberg
[Music]
uh before we present i just want to say
jessica
my favorite movie you did this year was
actually not an indie it was
interstellar
thanks andy that's that's really nice
yeah what a head trip right
i have so many questions about it you
know the science the wormy holes but
my number one question that i just have
to know is
what was it like kissing toe for grace
wait that's your question were his lips
just like satin pillows the way i've
always imagined
no i wouldn't say that oh come on now
j.j
be real with me stain guard those are
the nicknames i call you even though
we've never met before tell me about the
smooch okay okay
so um you know that feeling like when
your little girl and all your hopes and
dreams still feel real like you can
almost just reach out and touch them 100
yes
multiply that by 10 billion
to the point that all the time and
matter become secondary to a single
moment
which you now realize is time and is
eternity
wow
i gotta say thought it'd be better i
thought it would be better
you might not be describing it good
enough but yeah yeah maybe maybe that's
it
all right here are the nominees for best
male lead
best male lead
andre benjamin jimmy all is by my side
you know i should be like you do do
exactly what you're doing huh
you really want to change things
when the power of love takes over the
love of power that's when things will
change
jake gyllenhaal nightcrawler when i say
that i want these things
i mean that i want them and i don't want
to have to ask again
michael keaton birdman it's my chance to
finally do some work that actually means
something
this could cost you
anything if please play cost me
everything
john lithgow love is strange i have
wondered what you've been doing with
your three nights without me that's not
for me ben i'm sorry i can't say the
same to you george
but at least i've always been honest
with you david oyelowo selma if you
believe
all are created equal
come to selma
join us join our march against injustice
and inhumanity
[Music]
and the spirit award goes to
michael keaton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
wow it is a bird
look uh
this award season is unbelievable and uh
there is a lot of an awful lot of
picture taking of one and
interviews and talking and discussion
and uh
you're all
very aware of this i think we'd all be
uh
remiss if we didn't
take a moment and thank uh
narcissus
right now
he doesn't get enough of a shout out
in my opinion
[Applause]
and that award the mirror thing is just
genius anyway
uh this has really been fun honestly to
tell you the truth and i've got to thank
everybody over at that table like sean
and rachel and marny and nancy and arnon
and new regency and fox searchlight are
unbelievable they they're just
tremendous and i'm really hoping i don't
forget anyone that my cast
my cast alejandro's cast
the cast the crew the camera bears
everybody it was really this is an
extraordinary thing and i'm sure people
are sick of hearing me talk about it i'm
sure people are sick of hearing me talk
about anything frankly
all right well then
um
so i'll tell you this
first of all
that opening uh the birdman opening
thing that fred did and kristen did was
really funny really really really really
funny
and and these guys are really funny and
this is a really fun awards show and i
looked over at alejandro when they were
showing it and he was laughing but i saw
him thinking
oh man
i may have miscast my movie
i made a mistake and passed fred
um
when i met alejandro to
talk about this movie
he explained uh how he wanted to make it
uh
and he said i'm going to do it like this
and how do you work with your president
i intend to shoot it all in
oh one long shot
over the course of 37 years and i
thought come on now
that's been done first of all
and i thought it was indulgent uh he's
so fun to be around and um so
unbelievably
imaginative and such an artist and
everyone in in this group who made this
movie chibo
and everyone who jumped in
and had the guts to try something that
is for my money man i'm sorry that this
is this is bold cinema this is this is a
game changer
and i am really really really really
really really fortunate and blessed to
be part of something this this uh
bold and that's the only word i can
think of right now
and i'm unbelievably grateful for this
uh and this is a really fun award show
so thank you very very very much i'm
very grateful thank you
the biggest award of the night is next
as cate blanchett awards the year's best
independent film live when the 30th film
independent spirit awards continues
uh the piaget producers award which we
featured earlier in the show every year
gives out a grant to um a 25 000 grant
given to emerging producers of
independent film and i would like to
introduce this year's uh recipient chris
olsen
thank you
i want to thank
piaget and film independent for
for this fantastic grant and award and
more than anyone else i want to thank my
partners david and nathan zellner that i
made kamiko the treasure hunter with i
thank you guys for taking me on this
wonderful ride
and um
i want to thank the folks at the
sundance institute and the sundance film
festival who were
incredible in helping shepherd david
nathan and i along
with this film thank you so much
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome last
year's spirit award winner for best
female lead kate blanchette
[Music]
[Applause]
the five exceptional independent films
nominated for best feature each in their
own way do what all great films do
they illuminate illuminate what it means
to be human
they examine our lives unfolding our
responsibility to our families the quest
for equality and freedom and our desire
for greatness and our drive to create
something of value to leave behind
so here are the nominees for best
feature
birdman or the unexpected virtue of
ignorance
boyhood
love is strange
selma
and
whiplash
and the spirit award goes to
birdman or the unexpected virtue of
ignorance
oh
um
well it's
it's an honor it's truly truly an owner
received this award more than anything
because uh i think all of us uh here in
this room and all these filmmakers all
these films
honestly even when probably we are not
aware
as many animals in nature we are
threatened to become a species in
extinction
and and i think that all these films
differently from many others in a way
all of us share something that
all of them born from a need to be
expressed to some something to say
an individual expression and the way i
see it is i think cinema has these two
natures
which is the physical nature which is
absolutely interdependent
but the independent come from the spirit
and independent come from the only
condition to be
free from any subordinate or objective
of make money only and i think all these
films were an act of love and i feel so
proud and so emotional
to be here tonight with you really and
anyway
um
so many great filmmakers so many friends
i started making films not so long but
it's only 15 years but seems long all of
us has now gray hair
and
anyway to share this with all the people
because honestly
directing is not more than reproduce or
produce or create is just to vibrate
in consonants with souls and pick things
and people that really can make with you
something extraordinary and i think i
was lucky enough to work with all the
people in birdman
i don't know how to start but i will say
that
um this film will not be this film
without michael keaton really i think i
i think we
i have to say that
where is michael mike
well he's birdman he fly there
i i really have to to say that uh the
phenomenal cass edward norton jack sana
calafine panakis
uh
emma stone naomi watts amy ryan and
andrea larissenbauer i think all the
cast was a phenomenal thing i have to
recognize to my partners co-writers
crazy people nicolas jacobon armando
and alexander genelaris
my fellow partner producers john lescher
james scotch topol and obviously my
brother mr chivo lubesky the genius of
lights
antonio sanchez martin hernandez
anyway so many people stephen miriani
the editor that it was yes it was more
than two edits i can guarantee you that
um but uh and then honestly as somebody
was saying here is true well patricia
said that it's true that in a way film
festival like film festivals and art
houses and this kind of award is when we
can get together to celebrate the cinema
that is being forgotten and obviously
distributors too are part of that
force that we are basically
here
today and uh i want to really express my
my thankfulness to to brad weston to
arnold milton and all the people from
from uh new regency and to stephen lula
nancy utlin claudia lewis and all the
people of fox search like that really
they have really worked so hard to make
this film here really thankful thank you
very much
and finally i want to thank
my wife marilladia my daughter mariella
and eliza that is watching i don't know
where maybe with friends having some
tequilas but i love you very much and
thank you all for this thank you very
much
okay everybody um i know
that we all want to leave
but let's not
let's just hang out let's just sit down
let's look at each other just for
friendship talk to each other
come up and say hi to us no thank you
very much for everything uh we really
appreciate it we did have a lot of fun
today so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
film independent would like to thank its
premier sponsors official luxury watch
and jewelry partner piaget piaget
perfection in life official automotive
partner the lincoln motor company
lincoln is a proud supporter of
independent film official financial
services partner bank of america bank of
america life's better when we're
connected official beer sponsor heineken
heineken open your world official
airlines partner american airlines
american airlines the entertainment
industry's preferred airline our
broadcaster ifc ifc always on slightly
off and a special thanks to t-mobile
lenscrafters 10901 tequila breyer's
gelato indulgences keels since 1851 fiji
water netflix and moet and shandon
champagne film independence missions to
champion the cause of independent film
and support a community of artists who
embody diversity innovation and
uniqueness of vision film independent
members vote to decide the winners of
the spirit awards learn more about
membership and join at
filmindependent.org
membership
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you